this video is brought to you by
Squarespace whether you need a domain a
website or an online store make it with
Squarespace check out Squarespace calm
for a free trial you can find a link in
the description below
he achieved legendary status amongst
conmen by pulling off some of the most
outrageous brazen and unbelievable
deceits in the history of fraud by the
age of 21 he had impersonated a Pan Am
pilot a pediatric supervising doctor and
a lawyer
charming everyone he met and bouncing
checks all over the world in this week's
biographic s-- we take a look at the
incredible story of Frank William
Abagnale Frank William Abagnale was born
on April the 27th 1948 in New Rochelle
New York named after his father who
owned a stationery business Frank was
the third of four children
his mother Paulette was a French
Algerian extraction the couple met while
Frank's senior was on active service in
Algiers during World War two they were
soon married despite a thirteen year age
gap frank senior proved to be a very
successful businessman with the
stationery store doing exceptionally
well as a result the family lived in a
large home and although the Abagnale
were by no means rich Frank jr. and his
siblings had a comfortable childhood
[Music]
Frank attended I known a Catholic school
in Westchester New York and this world
was turned upside down in 1960 when his
parents separated this came as a shock
to all the children he thought that
their mother was a contented housewife
who had everything she ever wanted
however Frank senior was active in local
politics he was active in the
management's of the New York Yacht Club
and he also is a very keen deep-sea
fishermen all of these interests meant
that he was often away from home one day
he came home from an overseas marlin
fishing adventure to find that his wife
and kids had simply moved out
Frank Xenia he was crushed by the
separation he deeply loved his wife and
fought to get her back until the day
that he died the Paulette's mines it was
made up as a sign of Independence she
enrolled in dental college and began
building a life of her own
Frank Xenia he recruited jr. to help him
win back Paulette's affections he would
give us some gifts to pass on schooling
him on what to say and how to say it but
Paul s she wouldn't budge the couple
divorced when Frank was only 14
[Music]
unlike his siblings Frank chose to live
with his father this opens up a whole
new world for the teenager who had been
used to a regimented and disciplines
life with his mother tagging along with
his dad he began spending time in the
bars around New York as Frank senior
wheeled and dealed amongst the city's
businessmen and politicians the
experience it quickly made the boy very
streetwise it was around this time that
Frank began to skip school in order to
run with a handful of local Punk's who
were like him from dysfunctional
families and they were looking for some
way to express their frustrations Frank
who was bigger and more mature looking
than his associates which was handy when
it came to playing hooky he was often
mistaken for a teacher on an outing with
his students the group committed minor
crimes like sneaking into movie theaters
and stealing candy Frank soon became
frustrated of the childishness and lack
of sophistication of his partners in
crime though they did not exhibit any of
the class that he realized was key to
making it as a successful criminal
things came to a head when his friends
stole a car while the owner was watering
his lawn they swung by to pick up Franco
needs to be stopped by the police
moments later Frank and his fellow cons
were thrown into juvenile detention
Frank zinnias political connections
though they managed to get his son
sprung and to have any mention of the
incident it raised from the record
Frank's dad told him that he was wasting
his time hanging around with kids who
were clearly not as mature or as
sophisticated as he was it was time to
start acting like a man his father set
this pep talk it seemed to do the trick
and Frank began attending school
regularly he also got a part-time job as
a shipping clerk at a warehouse in
Bronxville to show his support for his
son's change of direction Frank senior
bought in his first car an old Ford
having a set of wheels opens up new
horizons for Frank specifically it
allowed him to meet and enjoy the
company of women the next couple of
years by his own admission he was
consumed with satisfying his teenage
libido he would cruise around town
looking for a young lady that he could
entice with his ever-growing charm into
an evening of intimate activity Frank
soon discovered that his sexual
excursions they cost money invariably it
after you supply his conquest with a
coconut burger in order to keep her
happy the roller was that his meager
finances did not allow for such an
expense Frank approached his dad's and
requested a gas charge card he promised
that he wouldn't abuse this privilege
and his father was impressed with his
sincerity he handed over his mobile card
soon after a month later Frank enacted
his first scam pulling into a Mobil gas
station he saw a sign announcing that
you can put a new set of tires on your
car and charge it to your mobile cart it
was then that he realized that you could
use the cart for other things aside from
gas thinking fast he approached no
attendance at the station that he was
familiar with Frank asked what it would
cost for a new set of tires and the
answer was a hundred and sixty dollars
Frank readily acknowledged that he
didn't need new tires but said that he
was desperately short of cash so he
suggested that he buy the set of tires
and charged them to the card but rather
than taking the tires the attendant
would give Frank a hundred dollars for
them he could then sell off the tires
for 160 dollars making a quick $60
profit 10 minutes later
Frank drove away from the mobile station
with $100 cash in his pocket and it was
that which hooked him over the next few
weeks Frank replicated the scheme at
different mobile stations around the
Bronx at times he would simplify the
deal offering the pump attendant to give
him ten dollars of cash while signing a
bill for $20 of gas it was only when the
bill from mobile arrived that Frank
realized that his father was the chump
who would pay for his excesses but Frank
he had a simple solution he threw the
bills into the waste bin of course
though that wasn't a solution at all it
didn't solve anything pretty soon a
mobile representative visited Frank
senior at his store and requested an
explanation for an outstanding
three thousand four hundred dollar bill
in three months after 15 years of
impeccable payment history Frank jr.
always calls in front of both men to
explain he said he didn't know what they
were talking about but neither man was
convinced finally Frank admitted it
offering this excuse it's the girl's dad
they do funny things to me I can't
explain it his father nodded with a wry
smile and replied don't worry about it
boy
Einstein couldn't understand it either
unfortunately for young Frank his mother
wasn't so understanding she blamed his
criminal activity on the influence of
his father and promptly organised for
him to attend a Catholic private school
for problem children Frank spent a year
there and during those 12 months his
father's financial fortunes took a steep
reverse and he lost almost everything he
was quick to assure his son that the
$3,400 that he had stolen was not a
factor in his money problems
[Music]
Frank left home at 16 he left without
saying a word to anyone hopping on a
train to New York City along with the
few belongings that he had crammed into
a suitcase he had in his possession of
checkbook that had $200 in the account
an hour off the train he had attached
himself to a teenage boy and convinced
him to take him home with him Frank went
on to spin a story about being an orphan
ins but he was determined to make it on
his own in the big city
the parents said that he could stay for
as long as he wanted the next day Frank
got a job as a stock clerk for one
dollar and 50 cents per hour he quickly
found out that this was not going to pay
his way in New York he figured that the
reason for his low wage was his age so
he simply altered the date on his
driver's license from 1948 to 1938 now
as a 26 year old he went out looking for
another job and he found one as a truck
drivers helper for two dollars and 75
cents an hour
Frank supplemented his income by cashing
checks from his account after a few days
he knew that his account was overdrawn
but that technicality did not face him
he continued writing bad checks on a
daily basis it didn't take him long to
rationalize that his time working for
2.75 cents an hour was simply not worth
the effort
therefore he quit and simply wrote more
bad checks
[Music]
one day while walking along 42nd Street
Frank was stopped in his tracks at the
sight of an aircrew from Eastern
Airlines emerging from the Commodore
hotel he was mesmerised as the captain
copilot flight engineer enforced
stewardesses breezed by Frank I wrote in
his memoir that he had never seen such a
splendid group of people his mind began
to work over time imagine if he was a
pilot he would have instant respects and
as a result he would be able to cash
checks anywhere with impunity continuing
down the street he found himself outside
of the Pan Am building quickly he
formulated a plan he returned to his
accommodation found Pan Am's phone
number rang and asked to speak to
someone in the purchasing department he
went on to inform the purchasing officer
that he was a Pan Am pilot based in Los
Angeles he was due to hop a flight back
home at 8:00 p.m. but his uniform had
been stolen he confidently requested a
replacement uniform the helpful
purchasing officer gave Frank directions
to the uniform company to pick up his
uniform he walked out with a complete
co-pilots uniform enhance what he needed
now was a pilot's ID card
he quickly had one made up of fixing the
Pan Am logo from a model plane that he
had purchased for $2.49 decked out in
his pilot uniform Frank walked him to
look Rottier Airport it was soon
approached by a TWA pilot who asked what
Pan Am was doing at LaGuardia it turns
out that Pan Am
did not fly out of LaGuardia picking up
on his research Frank replied oh I just
deadheaded in from Frisco on the first
flight I could cash or cash a chopper to
Kennedy the answer seemed to satisfy but
then the co-pilot asked what kind of
equipment do you want this through Frank
in his research he hadn't come across
the word equipment used in any context
searching for the right answer he came
out with General Electric the pilot was
actually asking what type of plane Frank
flew so the quizzical look on his face
that this reply was rather
understandable
Frank quickly made his departure he
didn't attempt to board a plane that
first day he was to spend some weeks
getting confident in his role as he
wandered the airport struck up
conversations with pilots and built his
store of shop knowledge during this time
he also found great success in cashing
checks in his pilots uniform in fact the
tellers they couldn't give him cash fast
enough finally ready to take to the
skies
Frank turned up at ligarius Eastern
operations office and informed the desk
clerk that he needed to deadhead to
Miami on the next flight assuming that
there was room on the plane editing was
the name used for the practice of
allowing staff to travel for free in
order to get to a job location he was
told there was a vacancy on a flight
departing in 15 minutes just a few
moments later he found himself in the
cockpit in a tiny seats that came down
from the door behind him with him were
the pilot copilot and flight attendant
after asking what type of equipment he
flew the three pretty much ignored him
for the rest of the flight before
getting off at Miami Frank made a date
with one of the stewardesses who was
laying over in Miami that night amazed
at how it's simple the whole process had
been Frank became a serial dead header
upon arriving in a city he would stay
overnight in a motel used by Pan Am
staff it charged the bills of the
company and in the morning before
heading to his next deadhead flight cash
a bad check for $100 or more just to
have some Betty cash this pattern
continued for the next two years between
the ages of 16 and 18 taking him to 26
countries on more than 250 flights that
covered in excess of a million miles by
the middle of 1966 Frank was ready for a
new gig he had experienced a close call
when someone had stated that he didn't
actually work for Pan Am fortunately his
bluster and feigned outrage got him
through the challenge but he knew that
eventually the game was going to be up
it was when applying for a long-term
lease on an apartment in Atlanta Georgia
that he on a whim wrote down his
profession as medical doctor when asked
what type of doctor he was he replied
that he was a pediatrician based in
California but was on a 12-month
sabbatical to audit some research papers
things went well for a period of time
until one day he got a knock at the door
his new neighbor introduced himself
Willis Granger dr. Willis Granger chief
resident pediatrician at the Smithers
General Hospital in Marietta Frank was
afraid that Granger would blow his cover
but fortunately the real doctor wasn't
one to talk sharpens they were able to
cross each other's paths without
incident meanwhile Frank spent as much
time as he could at the local library
reading up on the subject
of Pediatrics a few weeks later Frank
felt confident enough to accept an offer
from dr. Granger to toss Miller's
General Hospital after that he made
regular visits on one such occasion he
was approached by the hospital
administrator and asked to do a huge
favor could he cover a midnight to 8:00
shift for a doctor who would be away for
10 days due to a death in the family
Frank objected that he didn't have a
license to practice in Georgia but the
administrator countered that he really
wouldn't be doing anything during the
night shift just overseeing the interns
and nurses so long as he passed an
interview panel of five doctors
everything would be just fine Frank's
initial impulse was to refused there
were too many dangers involved here but
he was intrigued with the challenge and
so he agreed much to Frank's relief the
interview was light-hearted and non
inquisitorial he was now a nightshift
pediatric supervising doctor with eight
interns and 14 nurses under his control
in order to make it through Frank took
on the persona of a rule-breaking
anti-establishment practitioner in the
mold of Hawkeye Pierce on his favorite
TV show mash things went smoothly until
he was called to the emergency room he
took his time getting there hoping that
an intern would step in when he finally
arrived there were three interns
gathered around the patient Frank asked
them for their diagnosis and when all
three agreed he told them to go ahead
with the procedure at the end of his
10-day stint Frank was approached by the
administrator in informs that the doctor
he was replacing was not coming back he
was asked if he could stay on until a
replacement could be found he ended up
spending 11 months as a doctor at
smithers Hospital
[Music]
after finishing up at the hospital Frank
decided to leave Atlanta he moved to
Baton Rouge Louisiana where a mess up
with a flight steward that he had
formerly had a relationship with
remembering that Frank had told her
about his supposed law degree from
Harvard the girl introduced him at a
party to assistant state's attorney
Jason Wilcox on learning that Frank was
currently out of work Wilcox told him
that the Attorney General was looking
for bright articulate young lawyers he
suggested that Frank take the bar exam
and go to practice with them once again
Frank found it impossible to resist the
challenge on his third attempt he passed
the bar exam he was given a position in
one of the Attorney General's Civil
Department's the job was really that of
a glorified errand boy but Frank was
happy in the anonymity of the role
around this time he began dating a girl
named Gloria who was a staunch Methodist
through his relationship he ended up on
a church committee sitting alongside a
man who was a real graduate of Harvard
Law School
this guy began asking too many specific
questions and Frank knew that it was
time to pull the plug on his legal
career Frank legs turned up in Utah
where he claims to have scammed his way
into becoming a teacher at Brigham Young
University for eight months however the
university denies that he ever works
there
[Music]
by now Frank was wanted in many parts of
the world for a long list of fraudulent
activities the FBI were on his trail
Nazz was Interpol his luck finally ran
out while he was spending time in the
southern French town of Montrachet he
was arrested on the basis of an Interpol
warrant for fraud issued from Sweden for
fraudulent checks written during a visit
while he was supposedly a Pan Am
employee the French authorities they
soon discovered that he had written
false Jack's all over their country and
they refused to honor the extradition
Frank was sentenced to 12 months
imprisonment in France which after being
reduced to six months was served at
Papac non prison conditions were abysmal
and Frank's weight went from a hundred
and ninety eight to a hundred and nine
pounds during a stay that he was then
extradited to Sweden where he served
another six months upon his release from
Malmo prison in Sweden Frank was taken
into custody by US federal officials and
returned to the United States after a
third trial he was convicted to 12 years
imprisonment for multiple cases of fraud
during his time in US custody he escaped
twice but was recaptured on both
occasions after four years in jail Frank
was offered a deal his prison term would
be quashed if he agreed to be an uncle
consultant to assist the authorities to
investigate fraud cases Frank he agreed
after his release from prison
he took on a succession of menial jobs
only to be fired for not revealing his
criminal past he then decided to parlay
his vast criminal experience into a
legitimate career by becoming a security
consultant and advising companies on how
they could avoid the sorts of scams that
he had perpetuated for so long he went
on to set up his own fraud protection
company Abagnale & Associates
he has been advising the FBI on fraud
related matters for more than 40 years
Frank Abagnale aged 70 and 2018 lives in
Charleston South Carolina with its wife
Kelly they have three sons one of whom
works for the FBI now in today's video
you learned all about the identities
that Frank Abagnale took on over the
years but you know what establishes a
strong and legitimate identity these
days a beautiful personal website and
you can do that with Squarespace
Squarespace allows you to create a
powerful online identity maybe you're
like me and you
need a place on the web for people to
find you or maybe you're starting a new
business and you need to set up an
online presence or a store well you can
do it all with Squarespace on
Squarespace it all starts with a
stunning template and with names like
Pursuit and Royce you know they've got
to be cool seriously they are actually
very good-looking and cool so do check
them out or if you hate beautiful
templates not judging here you can start
from scratch
Squarespace make it super easy to make
something that looks amazing
you can also easily move over an
existing domain and if you posted a
website anywhere else you know that's a
good idea because it generally sucks
it's a lot easier in fact it's great if
you go with Squarespace and once you've
gone through the super easy
customization process there are no
updates no patches no tech BS to deal
with no one likes tech yes but you know
what everyone does like that would be
Squarespace is 24/7 customer support
they're there to help you whenever
you've got a question and Squarespace
it's not just about an online presence
as I said if you're starting a business
and wants to sell online Squarespace
great place to do it
look if you're looking to pursue a dream
or anything like that you need a website
and you can do that with Squarespace
there's no better way head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
Squarespace comm forward slash bio
graphics to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain thanks
to Squarespace for sponsoring this video
do subscribe to this channel for more
biographies every Monday and every
Thursday also hit that like button if
you liked it and I'll see you in the
next video
[Music]
[Laughter]
you